no when it was really a game when Gareth
Southgate side dispelled the doubters
that he'd been a poor run going into
this tournament six games without a win
but they scored six times to really put
on a show tonight and to kick-start
their World Cup campaign it all got
underway with Jude Bellingham a World
Cup debutant scoring because another
making his debut at the World Cup
scoring twice also getting gold from
Raheem Sterling he's been so reliable
for England in recent years and then we
had Rahim stir we had Marcus rashford
and then Jack grealish scoring the sixth
the only setback those uh two goals
conceded including one in the 13 minutes
of injury time from the penalty spot for
Iran but certainly England are now up
and underway with a big win and with me
are some fans who've been in the stadium
so introduce yourself uh John I'm
Russell
so what did you make of that fantastic
great turnaround from the Nations League
uh big fan of the of the team
oh just unbelievable you always you're
always worried they're going to start
slow but just one of what a way to play
you know it's fantastic now the accent
you are from the states yes yeah this is
my dad who's from England and but I grew
up in the states he brainwashed me early
enough to follow the Three Lions and of
course split loyalties to come because
the United States game still to come for
England of course they're playing Wales
in the later game in this group yes yeah
we're actually headed to that game as
well so supporting the U.S there and
then uh be an interesting game on Friday
then when it's against the us we want
another 6-2 win for England
and really something about this workout
the fact you can go to two games in a
day everything's so close in and around
Doha yeah yeah absolutely it's a big big
added bonus yeah yeah we've been Amazed
by how smooth everything's gone you know
we're worried coming here but
everything's been great so far fantastic
so who's going to win the World Cup the
us or England England all the way yeah
at home yeah drinking all the Coca-Cola
we'll have a great trip to the other
Stadium not too far from here you get to
a second set of 90 minutes though this
game went on pretty much longer than
that have a good trip across so yes I'm
delighted fans we get two teams to
support out here in Qatar but of course
it's not completely been about the
football has been talking about those
controversies the England players were
due to wear a one love Rainbow armband
Harry Kane as Captain was due to where
they decided against doing so this
morning hours before the game because
FIFA threatened them with sanctions the
threat of a yellow card potentially for
Harry Kane for wearing an unsanctioned
piece of equipment the armband not
permitted it was their attempt to show
solidarity with the LGBT community
particularly to highlight discriminatory
laws here in Qatar where same-sex
relations are banned England players did
though take a knee to highlight racing
and Justice just a reminder that England
see themselves as activists and using
their cam platform on the world stage to
do more than just compete and to perform